[Music]
and that's what we're here to say is
that we are the new black panther party
what's the biggest problem facing the
movement
well you know we supposed to be in this
era of so-called post-racial harmony
with all people in america but us blacks
are being murdered all over the place
and we get the same treatment time and
time again we're not even second-class
citizens we third class
stand up black america and declare the
white america that we aren't going to
take this no more okay why come out now
and say this you know what you have 400
years to get it right america but you
don't know how to treat your people all
people it's time to stand up it's time
to take back it's time for us to fight
back and we don't take your phony words
anymore we're not gonna do it we want
concrete results
you know you you hear what we're saying
to you united snakes of america
what are you supposed to do when the
whole world is watching and no one is
saying anything we will not be silent
okay you sir anything you wanted to say
oh me no i'm good
[Music]
[Music]
eight kilos
100
pure grade afghani heroin
[Music]
100 000
us dollars
[Music]
hold up
we should count it first
um i guess
you know we're gonna do a straight
counter on this right now count it count
it yeah it's a good idea
should probably do it fast so we don't
make our friends here wait okay
60 80
200. you know what i'm fast 20 students
okay i'll take care of that one two
three four five six seven eight nine one
two three four five six seven eight nine
one two three four five six seven eight
nine why are you doing piles of nine
it's faster than tens oh really i do my
nines ten times and then do an extra
pile of tanning fast
you know what we should we should
probably both be counting oh well this
you should get two at this double
trouble all right and 20 40 69 80 100
620 425 wait 60
i'm sorry can you could you plea could
you do something like over there please
it's a little distracting oh you know
what what's that i got it we could time
me
okay we time me counting out a thousand
yeah we take that time and then we just
count money from that time times 100.
yeah so that's those spindles no i i got
it this is it right here i'm gonna do a
web search
for a picture of one hundred thousand
dollars okay then you know we'll know
what it's supposed to look like and then
we can arrange our money to look exactly
like it and see here hey here we go
right here look i mean damn that looks
that looks just like a lot like our
money i think we got a hundred thousand
dollars here folks i think we made it
that is our money i'm sorry i'm sorry
earlier yeah we were counting i took a
picture of our money so i could upload
it on yahoo answers oh damn that's right
i just wanted to see if anyone could
verify what a hundred thousand dollars
look like oh you got it what was i
thinking i got it man go go go go go got
it
what the hell you doing man i you know i
was gonna try to rain man it
well that's a plan right there that's
right okay yeah here we go here we go
okay
yeah yep i got that i got that 246.
99 980.
uh i actually pressed it already huh the
walk button i i pressed it
couldn't hurt to press it again but it
won't help
i mean i
pressed it already right
it's already done
you don't think i didn't press it
no i wasn't saying that good because i
most certainly did press it yeah just
have to wait for the to change
[Music]
so i'm like late for work so i'm just
impressive what for why would you do
something that's already done
i mean i just think that that's crazy
right
i don't know you wouldn't suit up and
try to kill bin laden again it's done
i
have killed the bin laden of pressing
this button
how long ago did you press it
what do you think i've been standing
here for days i i just pressed it right
as you walked up are you sure you
pressed it am i sure i pressed it it's
how could i miss it
rats know how to press buttons do you
think i'm dumber than a rat no
no nobody's saying anything like that
it's gonna change just just wait
it's because i pressed it already
okay no offense
i'm just gonna press it what would you
do that for this is precision equipment
designed by people with engineering
degrees it will work i pressed it sir
i pressed the button while we've been
standing here the light cycle has gone
by twice okay i'm not saying you didn't
press it i'm just saying maybe it didn't
work if it didn't work for me why in the
world would it work for you
you think that it would change faster if
you
pressed it do you think the light
doesn't like me or something or do you
think that this particular button was
designed so that it only works after the
second time that it's been pressed cause
that's lunacy okay do you understand do
not check my balls off on this one okay
please
do not press the button
again okay fine
we'll just
stand here thank you
told you shouldn't have pressed the
button
told him not to do it
no actually i already pressed the button
[Music]
rick nicholsbee reporting live from a
gruesome scene a cult known as qet or
quest for eternal truth has apparently
taken their own lives in a mass suicide
police confirmed that cyanide laced
cherry kool-aid was also on the premises
excuse me hi rick nicholsbee channel six
hi are you two from the neighborhood oh
yes
yes
yeah
okay were you two members of the cult
that lived here the co what cult was
this a cohort i had no idea this was a
cult why well let's say the term cult is
a little judgmental i would say the same
thing not knowing the full doctrine
well apparently they believed that there
was a spaceship waiting for them behind
the moon okay well you know that that
still is really possible and it's
possible right i mean who knows what is
out there in the universe behind the
moon okay well it appears they killed
themselves in order to board the ship
right and that's where we disagreed with
them right there or would have we would
have disagreed with them had we been
there on on our departure day their
departure day their departure day which
is the day that they
did this
i mean that's what you could call it if
you wanted to i ain't in no call no i
mean what i always wondered is how or am
starting to wonder since you brought
this to our attention why if there was a
spaceship in the sky why wouldn't it
just beam up beam them up right sisters
just beam them up why can't you just
beat them up alive why you got to be
dead to get beamed up you know i've been
saying that for weeks seconds for
seconds because because you rick nichols
b you told us that uh you know and
that's how i knew because seconds like
50 seconds ago you said it i didn't know
anything about it until you had said it
because i ain't in no code okay well
then why would someone join a cult
dramatically leadership
you know like a compelling
person
i mean hypothetically they could have
had tacos on tuesday which would have
been a draw i mean that would have been
a plus okay so this is a tragic day for
this community and for the members of
the quest for earthly truth i'm rick
nicholsby reporting
you see yep you see
everybody drop the gun
we're ready
[Music]
best comic book adaptation to film hands
down no argument all right see you later
girls all right oh yeah um
i know i'm in the minority here but i
don't really like the christopher nolan
batman movies i don't i really just feel
like they're
overrated
okay
well that's um
that's just an opinion you see that's
why i prefaced it by saying i know i'm
in the minority
you know what no no
not really it's not awkward at least not
until you said awkward now it's awkward
because of what you said
anyway anyway what anyway what really is
because when you say anyway then you
have to follow it up with an actual
contribution to the conversation we're
having
yeah no look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me there's no yikes
and the reason why there's no yikes it's
just there's nothing scary about this
situation okay it's a very low stake
situation all right no not all right
come here no don't look at him don't
look at either of those guys look at me
all right
all right what because after you say all
right you have to follow that up with
something
don't do it
don't look at them
do not look at them
no no do not look at them do not look at
them don't tell us how you really feel
what i'll tell you how i really feel
listen i really feel like you're an
[ __ ] who has nothing interesting to
say so what ow no don't look it up
tell me an opinion that you have about
something just one opinion that you have
about anything at all just share an
opinion anything share an opinion share
an opinion share an opinion share an
opinion right now just on the top of
your head share an opinion anything just
one opinion that's all i'm asking share
one opinion right now
i don't have an opinion that's why i
just like everything that everyone else
likes in pop culture
[Music]
don't look at me
don't look at me
don't look at this
[Music]
okay
hey man this is your first time
no man i i've been doing zombie extra
work on this show since
day one first season man
my first time was your first time on
this show
my first time being
extra at all
ever kind of nervous oh wow okay man hey
man
i'm sorry about you you'll be all right
man it's okay man it's not that hard man
you'll be all right i'm me personally
dude i'm looking for that lunge bump
though
what's what's a lunge bomb oh that's uh
like if you um you get featured if you
lunge at somebody and then you get a
bump in your pay and if you really lucky
man they blow your head off that's
straight bank right there that's real
assistant director gather round jerry
hey jerry i had a thought man about the
first scene that y'all not now stan oh
steve it's steve okay okay i'm gonna
need somebody to lunge at the fence
you think you can handle it yeah
uh
yeah it's his first dado he's kind of
nervous man he's kind of nervous it's
his first day okay so the director's
gonna yell action mac's gonna come by
and then you're just gonna lunge into
the fence like
you you want me to say grah oh listen
say whatever's crazy okay all right cool
man hey you know hey that's cool hey you
know i got a lot more experience man you
can just use me i've been here day one
first season so and okay cool all right
that's fine you're gonna go with him all
right good for you man good for you guys
no don't you don't have to say god do
whatever hell you want to do man that's
the lunch box that is the lunge bump man
you got it you got it on your first date
ever
being an extra
ever you got it man good for you and
action
what the hell was that cut oh man i
would be more than happy to fill in man
i'd be more than happy to step in mac
just remember when you're coming through
the factory that hey like your mind is
still in the car i mean you all got to
pick people based on qualifications man
you can't just be picking random the
good note the crowd the note but maybe
what i was doing sort of superseded that
agreed yeah we were just discussing that
absolutely it supersedes it yeah but uh
let's do one that just seeds it okay
just same level we're going again
straight away okay right away okay
recently he's not doing a good job at it
you're doing great though man
opportunity knocks gonna answer the door
man
action
[Music]
i'll be more than happy to step in at
any time you want me to i'll be more
than happy to do it just a certain sense
of urgency is all we're looking for
clock's ticking you've got survivors to
find right can't tell you off but
something real segmented this dude right
here is not doing what a zombie does
this dude was literally on our last take
waving his hand up in the air like this
jerry making beaker sounds he sounded
like beaker
from the muppets y'all thank you that's
great just a ticking clock on this is
all we're looking for because there are
survivors that's what we're after okay
i found the ambivalence in there
the ambivalence is art it's gorgeous and
we love it but there are zombies so if
we could just pick up the pace just a
hair that'd be great straight away
please right away jerry we're not doing
night of the living muppets are we we're
not cause the beaker is not a zombie do
you have any notes yeah don't be a
beaker quiet please action
i'm gonna eat your brains zombie god no
he actually just said the word zombie
come on man you ever hear a zombie say
the word zombie before no you haven't i
don't think so you know what get rid of
this guy thank you that's what i'm
talking about i'm sorry don't be too
terrible at this man do your thing hey
man no he's talking about him no he's
talking about him because he said
zombies thank you steve no you want me
to leave hey man i've been up here
staggering around here for three and a
half years and i've been startling
extras left and right when do i get the
start of the lead huh one more for
safety straight away here
action
hey what do we do if we have to go to
the bathroom
we like it i love it genius moving on
thank god
[Music]
yellow falcon what do your senses tell
you destructo is a killing machine
his armor is impervious to our blisters
you got any ideas red falcon sure do
yellow falcon blue falcon you remember
our battle at dango bluff i'll take the
legs you take the blasters it was beaver
creek and i took the legs make sure you
shore up that flank black falcon
um
are you talking to me because i'm the
green falcon
no time for that black pelican purple
falcon our missiles roger that farming
missile now
uh battle formations we're going in hey
roger's good hold up copy that frankie
my falcon is green hey hey hey we can
talk about our falcon colors when we get
back to base black falcon right now we
got a mission to do fall into falcon
formation
well here's the issue is that you're
gonna give me an order i'm not gonna
know you're talking to me
cause i'm not in the black falcon come
on chill it out black falcon yeah black
falcon relax first of all i don't like
the way you guys are saying black second
of all there is no black falcon i'm
green falcon black falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your grill here
uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh don't talk to me like
that no don't say grill like that
i'm the green
falcon
and i'm stopping so black falcon about
it what the [ __ ] do you mean by that
black falcon brother i understand what
you're going through do you no i don't
think you do
how would you feel if i called you red
falcon huh whoa
and purple falcon how would you feel if
i called you yellow falcon huh that's a
racist that was racist yeah that's
racist oh that is racist that's racist
oh see okay nope forget it black falcon
out green falcon
green falcon dammit
hey why'd that green falcon fall out of
falcon formation black falcon get on
that report back
black falcon
black falcon come in
excuse me big man big man big man excuse
me big man no but big man okay god bless
you i'll catch you on the uplift thank
you big man thank you big man
hey brother hey can i ask you a question
real quick though brother man oh see
that's good cause i was about to ask you
a question okay so here's the deal man
crazy thing my car went out of gas but a
mile up the road that's a way i just
wanna get a little bit of money you know
just get a couple of gallons okay that's
crazy because you know what this my car
had also broke down right up the road
yeah i got my daughter here she's fine
she's sleeping in the car i got to get
back to her real quick so if you could
help me out i was gonna ask you if you
could help me also okay let me just give
you my wallet out here and show you my
id to let you know that i am scraped up
legit it's real i ain't trying to try to
do nothing to nobody okay uh issue of
legitimacy i do have an identification
that's an employee id from borders
bookstore right here i got my valley's
total fitness id right here shows you
that i stay fit and conscientious and
whatnot you'll also notice that these
other ids i have my hand have the same
name on it which makes you know that it
is indeed me okay i to have multiple ids
crescendoing in this
yogurtland punch card okay yeah you see
that right there that is i'm of my ninth
purchase apparently and you can free
tenants yogurt for that yeah
all right so normally i would not ask
another person for assistance but our
our family is in a fiduciary crisis
right now my wife is languishing in the
hospital she a construction worker and
what happened is she got struck in the
face by a power line fry the whole head
up burnt both eyeballs out she's getting
eyeball replacement surgery as we speak
i also have a spousal injury crisis on
my midst as well my wife was in the
astronaut program making her a
full-fledged astronaut okay and she had
gotten moon dust in her lungs in hell
yeah that's never good no it's never
good we don't want that so maybe we
could find an atm or something like
somewhere
oh look there's one over there
what's what's the chances of it we
should probably check that out yeah
let's just take a look right there
here we are well here we are atm
machines that i did not know previously
were here all right two of them no less
i'll tell you what we should do though
man you give me the 20 okay i'll give
you the three that's on my person then i
will give you the 17 after then you give
me that 17. i'll cut you a check for a
hundred just to cover that you give me
the change in cash okay okay i feel that
why am i playing i'm just going to give
you my atm card so you know i'm legit of
course i'm gonna give you my atm card so
we both have something of value from the
other person all right
and your code is it is one
two three four and you're sir one two
three five i thank you
[Music]
okay that that is a ralph's rewards card
okay that is a credit card placeholder
you would find in a translucent sleeve
and a brand new wallet
excuse me big man
right quick right quick to ask you a
question biggest of mine right quick
hey man
you gotta let me out of here
oh okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
you tricked me
i can honestly say
i wasn't trying to trick you
you weren't
all i said was you got to let me out of
here there's no trick
so so i do have to let you out of here
yes okay
[Music]
[Music]
orders to let him go i don't know why
he's in there in the first place i don't
know
[Music]
[Applause]
look you really got me in trouble
sorry yeah you must think i'm stupid
well i'm not stupid i'm smart so yeah
you know how you can prove that you're
really smart oh yeah let me guess you
want me to let you out of here again
well you know what you think you you can
trick me
into letting you out again
well you can't
because this is my choice
get the heck out of here all right all
right
reverse psychology
[Music]
i am sorry about that guys
that was me guys my bad my bad
real nice now they said they're gonna
dock my pay and if i let you out of here
again i'm going to be severely punished
i'm actually surprised they haven't
already thrown you in here with me no
prison is for bad guys you're you're a
bad guy and i'm a good guy
yeah but you can see how from my
perspective
i'm a good guy
wait you're a good guy oh my gosh
it doesn't seem like you understand what
your job is
oh okay
i see what you're doing you're trying to
you're trying to manipulate me with
reverse psychology well it's not gonna
work
it's not even worth going out there
again look they're just gonna get me
and
bring me back in here
just like they always do
[Music]
unless what
no i'm
forget it i don't want to take advantage
of him anymore look hey look listen
i'm not going to fall for it whatever it
is
you may as well just tell me
i was just gonna say that like if you
were to help me uh-huh
get past the guards yeah yeah all the
way out okay i i really i have to tell
you
you need to think about this long and
hard
weigh your options and consider the
ramifications of those options that's
like heck i will
let's go
i'm busting you out of here don't
[Music]
oh boy i did it again
i was a prison guard i wasn't allowed to
talk to the prisoners that was the thing
they said to me if you talk to those
prisoners you're gonna get trouble now
[Music]
what are we doing in this neighborhood
come on this place is in our price range
besides i mean people say the
neighborhood's turning around
it's jordan and kyra we're here to view
the apartment at three
oh
my bad
i had this homeless crackhead trying to
set up house in here yesterday
almost had to beat his ass man but y'all
ain't got nothing to worry about cause
anybody try to get up in here i will
murder them
let me give y'all a tour
all right so we got these vintage
windows they've been here as long as the
building been here
hey
hey you
i see you out there you get out that car
and i will murder you
that's what i thought
the roll on luke
my nephew craig
you good kid
he's no crack though
it's uh just in case
all right i filed a serial number off
there so if you got to shoot anybody
just make sure to wipe your fingerprints
off this month
oh come on y'all ain't gonna bite you
brand new cupboards
i put the contact paper in myself here
so y'all don't get no germs
get down
all right
ain't no dang
i thought craig was rolling back i ain't
getting shot by this twice damn while we
down here check this out
original hardwood floor from when the
building was built check out this green
brother
that is craftsmanship anyway come on
now this paint is all new
it
oh
okay this this happened after i had
painted it funny story we got crackheads
in this neighborhood and one of them
living right next door here right and
one day he was smoking crack just went
looney tunes and mistook his nine
millimeter that's a pistol honey for the
remote control but don't worry you ain't
never gonna see him again
ain't nobody ever
gonna see him
again
plus i'm gonna put a fancy little hook
in there and turn it into a hat rack
now let's take a look at his bedroom
what up
i ain't found this place first found it
man i own this place can you all give me
a second
i will cut you with my sword cane
so that's gonna be first month of last
month right one month security deposit
i'll get the paperwork started
okay baby let's hit this rock real quick
father please hear our prayer for the
poor thank you father yes we beseech you
for the disenfranchised the less
fortunate and those that suffer
show us your will
so we can continue to do your work yes
i have come to answer your prayers
listen carefully to my instructions
hallelujah
i want you to sell everything you own
and immediately begin service to the
poor
[Music]
just want to clarify um
to everything
yes
rid yourself of all earthly possessions
[Music]
oh
this house is on it
ah
i see what they did there
this place is so nice
this is
supposed to be one of the best uh french
places in town
i did not realize that you were so
cultured
you're sweet uh
my french is
pretty good
so uh i can order for both of us
also welcome to shea de la morton
berendra i am your waiter for this
evening my name is jean-luc de la pierre
renault but you may call me john
oh look at you
if you have any questions about anything
at all i'm more than happy to uh assist
you
i got it
messy
well our first special tonight is our
poisson du jour is a loop de mercu of
this song
served with a plumer vert de cochon
diplomat that is served on a pedestrian
dante
our other seafood today we have a very
nice flamethrower crowned the plos
advance from the guten museum valley
investment it is served with the side of
colombo fontonio de la mata
do god from here cologne sauce
man it's just
i'm a little bit overwhelmed
yes oh god i'm so glad you said that i
was about to say the same thing you
would recommend getting the front pan
grand dump to plump several with the um
oh i'm sorry is the pillow right
and a heavy falls on that sauce oh no no
no it's more like a question
what do you think i'm i'm going to defer
to him on this one because he knows this
stuff way better than i do
miss you
what
um yeah we're uh we'll have the
um
i'm
foreign
it's been nice knowing you have a lovely
dinner
[Applause]
look rasheed i'm going to make this
really nice and easy for you i need
names and you're going to give them to
me you have to listen to me you have to
listen to me
this is all
a huge mistake
apartment of homeland security's been
monitoring your calls for weeks regime
we got you
we know about you and your friends
we know that you're a terrorist
i am a terrorist
we me my friends we breed dogs
specifically terriers we write terrorist
fiction
we we spend a good deal of time
discussing possible future terrorist
plots
it's a nice try
really is
but it's bull rashid
come on is that the best you got what
now come on i'm listening just tell me
tell me
tell me about this imminent attack
what what what the [ __ ] i don't know
what to do
what are you talking what am i talking
about i don't know huh i don't know what
you're talking about what about you no
you don't know i don't know i don't know
june 11th rajid
you spoke of an imminent attack oh oh
yes
that was my friend listen his dog bit
him and i told him if you do not train
them another terrier attack is imminent
she lied and you see what happens
come on regine i like you
let's be friends huh
now you still haven't explained to me
why we found on the search engine of
your computer the words target
washington 49 times that that is because
i was in dc for a dog show and i had to
buy a squeezy toy a birthday card and
some deodorant all at an affordable
price all right
you can only do that again yeah okay i
see how you want to play this
this is not a case ah mistaken identity
and you know it
we've heard the conversations between
you and jafar were you discussing your
hatred of american ideas
american idols i hate them they perform
dancing queen it was a desecration
throughout
my favorite band
we got you on tape referring to jafar as
one of the architects of 7-eleven
it was 7 11.
[Music]
he designs convenience stores
7-eleven
oh
wilson 65 dogs just attacked the capitol
building
were the terriers
how did you know
it is so good to see you keith yeah we
usually have to wait for a special
occasion well actually i have a little
surprise i
got engaged
yes
wow
congratulations little bro
engaged kind of a big deal
more for me i guess that's what that
means
about um
she got a name uh stephanie marriage
is a wonderful journey 50 and the
divorce
sorry bro
them is just the facts
i will uh we'll keep that in mind thank
you
you got a photo oh yeah aka does she
exist
there you go
oh she is beautiful
let me get eyes on this
everybody else already huh
great lighting
airbrushed i know
she kind of looks like that one model uh
on the price is right uh
yes that's her
the price is right clive that's your
show shut up mom no it's not
uh
stephanie
people always under bid on their
showcases not the best presenter
where's the wedding oh uh in hawaii
oh
[Applause]
she ever been married before uh no so
she says
ex-boyfriends you got one
of course sloppy seconds at least right
dad
keith she sounds wonderful
shut up
mom
silence from you okay you're cut off
from talking
you know what clive
i really don't appreciate the way that
you're talking to mom
yes
yes
the prodigal son hath returned you know
what
you want to go let's go cause i've been
here for the last 15 years taking care
of mom and dad well you've been dropsing
all over the world and why so you can
come back here and criticize me for how
i treat them no
i actually came here
to ask you if you would do me the honor
of being my best man
i know that we have uh
had our differences
but you're my older brother
we'll pay for your room
and we're also going to rent you a car
and we'll pay to fly you out there
first class
well we can't afford first class well
you
you're dead to me
why shut up
i'm eating in my room
well that uh that went better than
expected
i think so
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
hey man how you doing here you guys got
bow and arrows
yeah yeah
oh yeah oh that's it yeah there it is
there that'll do it that's gonna do it
yup where are the arrows at
yeah you guys got it middies we don't
carry fireworks damn you have uh you
have something else that's explosive
that i could tape to the end of an arrow
we have shotgun shells but i feel i have
to ask are you planning to attach those
to arrows and use them as a weapon what
no what are you crazy you think that
would work though
what if i shot explosive arrows through
a window to break them open
sir i feel like i have to ask you what
you're planning to use these for oh i'm
not planning to do anything i'm just
just christmas shopping you got zip
lines nope but you got like hooks and
anchors and cables we got some of those
things but i do not recommend
manufacturing your own zipline oh i'm
not doing that no
let's say somebody was manufacturing
their own zip line do you think if they
had busted some windows open on a
building somehow then fired the zip line
off a bow and arrow and it attached to
the wall of said building that they
could just ride the zip line into the
building
i have no idea sir whatever you're
planning on doing please don't do it i'm
not i'm not doing anything i'm just
doing some christmas shopping trying to
get it out of the way you know bow and
arrows from her nephew the zip lines for
my
grandmother etc and whatnot you know
what i'm saying there it's nothing no
big deal speaking of other things do you
guys have just the uh top half of a
knight in armor
first of all it's called a suit of armor
oh yep that's it that's right that's
what i had to say we have one but it's
sold oh complete set yep yep yep yeah
well the person has four they only need
to they don't need they just need the
top half they don't need the legs
well what if somebody was shooting at
you
what were the chances you think they'd
try to shoot your legs i feel like i
have to tell you that a suit of armor
will not deflect bullets
i'll take my trip
with christmas
which brings me uh to my next question
do you guys have roller skates i think
we have a pair around uh-huh let me ask
you a question how fast do you think you
have to be going on roller skates you
get past a couple of arm guards and
still be going fast enough to smash
through a safe door one of those big
bank safes no
i don't i don't know yeah yeah
uh
hey you guys just got one of those you
know this is one of those big bags with
a dollar sign on the side of it okay
you're gonna shoot arrows with shotgun
shells attached to them to a bank window
to blow out the glass then you're going
to shoot a zip line through that window
and you're going to slide on into the
hallway you're going to be wearing
roller skates so you can just skate on
past the armed guards who will be
shooting at you and you're going to hope
that they both won't hit your legs and
if they are aiming at your torso the
suit of medieval armor will deflect the
bullets then you're gonna hope to gather
enough speed to burst through the big
bank vault at the end of the hallway
where you're gonna collect the money in
a cartoon money bag
well no i'm just an uncle's wife for
christmas and i think i'll take my
business elsewhere merry christmas
it's april
neal
neal
yes honey
neil degrasse tyson i asked you to take
the dog out for a walk when i left the
house four hours ago now i'll come back
and this little motherf sputnik has done
pissed on my drapes
now i've got to get rid of those things
and get new ones
neil it doesn't make any sense you're an
astrophysicist how can you not keep
track of little details like this
[Music]
well
actually
it's the little details that cannot be
kept track of by definition
in 1927 a german university lecturer
named warner heisenberg came to a
seemingly paradoxical conclusion
that the more we know about the position
of a particle in physical space the less
we know about its momentum and vice
versa uh oh okay but what taken in
conjunction with what we know about the
expansion of the universe this brings us
to a fascinating possibility
that maybe
what we experience as one point in time
space could actually be a legion of
points which would mean
that your curtains and little sputnik's
pee-pee could be as distant from one
another as we are from the furthest
galaxy
oh
okay
well just
next time
of course dear
neil
there you are
what are you doing
we have to go to my aunt nelly's funeral
how are you not ready
i've been talking to you about this all
week how am i going to find you in your
boxers looking in a science magazine
i swear neil
sometimes i think you don't have any
idea of what's important
well
actually
an idea of what's important is as close
as we can ever come to any definition of
importance
our galaxy is one of over 100 billion in
the observable universe
and it's a hundred thousand light years
across
which means it would take light 100 000
years to traverse okay but but that's
just space
if we were to chart
the history of the universe on one
calendar year
the history of mankind as we know it
would just take place in the final
second of that year so
whether i'm ready now or in 500 years
well
cosmically speaking the distinction is
meaningless
well
okay
[Music]
i'm i'm going now
goodbye honey
hey
who is she who is the white [ __ ] that
left this goddamn lipstick stain on your
collar
hmm
oh i got you
you're caught
because this is apricot colored and you
know who wears that white [ __ ]
and you can't talk your way out of this
one because i'm not getting confused
today because i got my order and i've
done my research okay neil
you see
we are here at this point in space-time
on a human scale but at this point you
were trifling ass mother
so expect the papers from the lawyer
because we're part ways
well
actually no nope we are always parting
ways and not parting ways in every
conceivable combination
many physicists including stephen
hawking now believe that there is an
infinite number of universes
it's called multiverse theory
and it suggests that there are an
infinite number of universes in which
i didn't have sex with that white woman
bill nye the science guy you [ __ ]
in the morning
yo joey blunts here at 101.3
hey everybody man we still trippin on
that last segment that was crazy
[Applause]
all right so no
so he would want to but he can't do it
because of that fat ass
why why why y'all always clowning on me
ball me ball
i brought it up for real though
oh you all left her first oh
[Music]
we'll be right back
[Applause]
just
hey watch where the [ __ ] you going oh my
gosh i'm so sorry
oh
i didn't see you had a baby there man
i'm sorry i ain't trying to fight nobody
with a baby
yeah hell yeah you won't
lucky [ __ ] huh well you're lucky
i'm carrying this baby somewhere that
look man you need to move on all right i
already told you i'm not gonna fight you
huh that's what i thought punk
wanna go cause we can go right now dog
what's going on man what the hell are
you doing man what what what what what
trying to i can bob and weave it what
your bitch-ass punk-ass [ __ ]
let's go come on man come on don't look
at your boys look at me man don't look
at you boy
ow
oh okay you think you hard all right but
you know what i'm gonna show you what
time it is right now okay
slap me i'm right how about this huh not
what you're gonna do huh now it's gonna
do you ready because they can do it
right now cause i can take you out man
you're not gonna
oh
oh it's on now that's yep you did
you did
excuse me i need
this yes
what now man
what now
let's go you know what
it's not even worth it man
that's what i thought so keep walking oh
okay that's about it
that is vomit
oh dear okay but do i look in the camera
no oh i do all right
like on television all right
now knock it off all the stupid ass grab
ass and touch it feel it bull
god damn i told you they was rotten
[Music]
i am uh ponibus jackson uh principal
here at klotho uh
vince cloth oh hi
uh
this uh station's just a formality
there's a bunch of stuff that we
confiscated just this week
this stuff you don't have to show them
that here's a wand with a silencer on it
why
but i asked again why one out of five
girls in this school is pregnant with a
demon baby
okay
ain't no dining
the babies are evil
but
the mothers they're good kids as we say
at chlorotholes uh there's never a
portal that cannot be opened with
ingenuity and respect
now
how you're gonna be using an invisible
cloak when i can see you tagging the
damn wall dime bag of pixie dust
contraband let's see here's the thing
the kids know that the only way to fly
wizard pepper unbelievable
get your ass out of my office i will
turn you into a spider
they're good kids hogwarts and claw
those claw those and hogwarts go hand in
hand the best top two wizarding schools
there are
but you know uh out of these two schools
we each have a strength we do score a
little bit lower on our standardized
tests than hogwarts but there is a
cultural bias
we may not have a huge endowment like
they get over at hogwarts and yes uh
some of the teachers have to buy their
own newt's eyes or bat wings one kid got
transformed into a cat they can't even
afford a changing bag this young man's
name is jamar
normally not allowed to touch the
students like this when they're in human
form
but uh when they're cat we just
have at it
sports
everybody loves sports it's everybody
the hallways are a bluster with the
conversation of our quidditch team half
the team is back here riding mops we got
two little [ __ ] on swiffer listen
when all is said and done uh the average
klortho student uh said this mother
sometimes the kids think it's cute to
turn themselves into a rat
sneak into my office play a little joke
on me who is that tyrone is that is that
no that's an actual rat
[Music]
[Applause]
hey here's the deal 100
grass-fed japanese kobe beef 35 a pound
that's what i'm talking about all right
let's grill these little homies up
right all right oh man is that ground
chuck man
i know i'm fancy i ain't trying to park
my bentley next to your toyota
oh you're just putting them right next
to the frozen pan yeah all right relax
man i'm gonna cook em good okay
all right so uh how's theresa doing
she's good she's good she's sad she
couldn't be here you know she's got a
closing today you wanna flash cook those
because they're real lean you know
they're grass fed so you just wanna
probably flip them right right now
hey who wants cheese on that burger
nobody nobody nobody wants cheese
anybody want a double burger no nobody
wants a double burger we're not gonna
double that's like putting a diamond
ring on a pig i'm sorry but the grass
that these cows ate cost more than this
house all right no double burgers
hey what the hell you may as well just
poop on that what you just ketchup raped
my kobe burger this was a mistake
this
no
no no oh no no no no no no no no see
this meat came all the way over here
from the pacific ocean
by boat
because the air pressure
wouldn't ruin any integrity
give me that
you are not worthy i'm not brother all
right look
it's 126 oh this little mother
126 dollars was to be
y'all not worthy
did he take my dog
hey all i know is it's good having
another brother moving to the
neighborhood hey man it's good to have
you over
and i think that you will dig this all
right
hey huh
nice guitar collection oh thanks man hey
you want to hear something
yeah sure all right
all right let's get this toy
[Music]
well i'm just a good old american boy
with a heart that's red white and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue
country music i grew up in texas you
know so
all right keep her safe from the homies
in the wrong side of town where they're
smoking the reefer and acting like
clowns
keep that pretty white dress from
getting dirty and brown cause that's
oh
pretty racist song
racist against who
black people
black people but i'm black
well
keeping the redheaded girl away from the
homies on the wrong side of town homies
come on brother there's all kinds of
homies
white homies asian homies
no homies are black no i think you're
making them black man i mean i think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried i think
we all know who we're talking about
the only dark i like is when i turn off
the lights the only hood i love is
pointy and white and trust you if i
can't see your face at night i think we
all know we're done
hey
stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only hood i love is pointy
and white yeah man
let's talk about the klan man
the ku klux klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing i would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know what can i just say
something man i'm just going to be frank
you're getting a little like al sharpton
like um farrakhan on me right now oh my
god are you serious
dude hey give me you know can i do one
more let me just do one more dog i
absolutely promise you that this song
is not racist and it's impossible for
you to misinterpret it as such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far i'm not
hiding
get me a roping family tree
okay
i'm out
come on man hey
over here trying to sing about a tire
swing
write off an entire genre of music
the banjos are struggling and the drums
are a banging let's get the boys
together and have ourselves a hanging oh
damn
now i see it
now i see it
[Music]
oh
[Music]